to protect citizens from the twenty  seven remaining EU countries members  approved contingency plans in the event  of an Odile brexit cooperation and areas  like transport erasmus+ and border  control should not be disrupted  propaganda from foreign actors and the  misuse of personal data should not  undermine the 2019 European elections  members called for stronger efforts to  tackle data protection breaches and  misinformation the EU is outlining its  roadmap on climate action up to 2050  members gave recommendations to reach  greenhouse gas emissions reduction goals  approximately nine million Europeans  have taken part in citizens initiatives  since 2012 Parliament adopted new rules  to strengthen participate ori democracy  and make it easier for citizens requests  to be seen by lawmakers